Let’s talk about what everyone is talking about:
the new coronavirus.
Is this the Big One?
Honestly it’s hard to say
but it’s moving fast and it doesn’t look good.
What started in the city of Wuhan in early December
has now grown into a global health emergency.
And as the contagion spread beyond China so did the fear.
I’m really afraid that the virus might infect me
or my family members.
We all have questions.
How contagious is this new virus?
What are the symptoms?
And how do we stay safe?
So this is what we’re dealing with:
a virus they started calling 2019-nCoV.
The N’s for novel, meaning new
and CoV stands for coronavirus.
And this is what it looks like.
It’s like viruses we’ve seen before
and comes from the same family as SARS and MERS.
But we’ll explain the science in a bit.
First let’s get a sense of how we got here.
It started with a viral blip:
a few cases of pneumonia in Wuhan.
Then doctors noticed that many of the people
who were sick had a connection
to a market that sold fish and wildlife.
From there the virus spread until tens of millions of people in China
in China were put under quarantine.
Wuhan was locked down first.
”Flight has been cancelled.”
Airlines pulled flights and trains stopped running.
Schools and businesses were closed
and people were told to stay indoors.
And although some residents
were making light of the lockdown
many are struggling to hang in there.
They just don’t know how long this is all going to last.
The virus has now been found in all of China’s 31 provinces.
It’s put the country on high alert.
In a rare move the government has closed
the Forbidden City here in Beijing
over health concerns related to the coronavirus.
People are avoiding any kind of place where there's crowds.
So therefore sports arenas, hotels, bars, restaurants
movie theatres are not going to be doing very well
for quite some time.
Stock markets took a dive and there’s talk about
the global economy being dragged down.
So what do we know about coronaviruses?
Well they’re common and usually found in animals.
But six of them were known to infect people.
This new one takes that up to seven.
Four of those strains are
pretty harmless.
And might cause things like a cold.
The others are killers.
Severe Acute Respiratory Syndrome showed up in 2002
and killed one in 10 patients.
Experts think SARS jumped the species barrier
from the civet cat to humans through bats.
In 2012 it was the Middle East Respiratory Syndrome
which kills roughly one in three people who get it.
MERS is thought to have come from camels.
Now SARS disappeared in 2004
but a few cases of MERS did pop up recently.
And now there’s this new strain
which we’re still trying to understand.
It’s already killed a lot of people
but it’s too early to tell what the mortality rate is.
We also know that early cases were linked
to that market in Wuhan where we know live animals
were in close contact with people
which is not unusual in Chinese markets.
It would’ve given that mutated virus
ample opportunity to find a human host.
This virus, this novel coronavirus that we're seeing
out of Wuhan, is 96% similar to a virus carried by bats
that we have studied in China.
So this also is a bat virus
and the big question is how did it get into this market?
One of the problems with this virus is that
it's hard to tell if you have it.
It might just feel like you have a cold.
We know it can give you
a cough
and a fever even shortness of breath.
But one in five people get severely ill
and have developed pneumonia, kidney failure.
Some have died.
So you don’t want to wait too long before you see a doctor.
Ultimately how badly it
affects you seems to
depend on how strong your body’s immune system is.
Of the people who have so far died
most of them were elderly
and most of them had an underlying illness.
So for the moment, you know, the doctors
the experts are telling us we do not need to be too alarmed
because at the moment we're not sure
just how deadly this virus is.
One thing we know is that the virus incubates between
two and 14 days beforea person
shows signs of being sick.
But it’s been a struggle to understand
how contagious it is.
China’s National Health Commission said that
a person without symptoms is still infectious.
Which is pretty scary.
But the WHO backed away from that
and said the most common way of getting the virus
is from people who are already visibly sick.
So how does it travel?
Scientists are working off clues based on
how SARS and MERS behave.
With those two the virus travels from person to person
through droplets that can enter someone’s body
through their nose, mouth or even eyes.
And that generally requires close contact.
Best-case scenario is that it has a strong seasonal impact
and that as the climate warms up in China
it sort of dwindles away by itself.
But I’m afraid that’s not very realistic.
Something else we know is the virus’s genetic sequence
which China made public in the early days of the outbreak.
This DNA map has helped scientists come up with
a test to diagnose the virus.
It might also lead to a vaccine.
A vaccine is of course the long-term solution
because developing one takes time
and costs millions of dollars.
So right now it’s all about the emergency response.
We’re talking about treating thousands of people
many of them suffering alone in hospital beds
away from their families and probably feeling pretty scared.
The health workers taking care of them are too.
And they’re overwhelmed.
Across China medical supplies including diagnostic kits
have been running out. So has bed space.
In response the Chinese government built
two field hospitals in Wuhan from scratch
in a matter of weeks.
And one factory in Thailand put in overtime
to make more surgical masks
even though not all medical experts are convinced
they’re much protection in public.
There’s a lot of fear and misinformation
out there right now
so while the scientists are working out
how to contain the outbreak
here’s the general advice from the experts.
Stay away from people who are sick.
If you’re ill see a doctor sooner rather than later.
Cough into your elbow or a tissue, not your hands
to avoid spreading germs.
And wash your hands. A lot.
You know: the basics.